the great logan webb wow he has been
fantastic especially in the last 12 13
starts
wong's numbers even better on the road
this year chop shot for crawford the
gold clubber handles it for out number
one
that's a hot shot to belt he found it
the toss to webb covering for the out
with plenty of time
yelich going to left side and brandon
crawford makes a sweet play fading away
real quick before i go to break over
under three runs for milwaukee today
under not over
there you go
the pressure's on
lower just now making his fourth start
coming off the covet i l but on the
season two mid threes era we begin with
austin slater
last night 0 for three with a walk and
this time first pitch going after it
deep center field and forget about it
austin slater muscles up and the giants
are on the board with one pitch it's
their first lead of the series make it
one nothing on his tenth of the season
[Applause]
belt roller
wong is as good as it gets at the
keystone two gone
you were talking about
look
tyro strata going after the first pitch
aligns it to left and christian yelich
is there
logan webb picks up his first strikeout
after three grand balls in the first
it's all working for logan webb so far
this season he picks up another
strikeout
secondary pitch
they really enjoy working with kirk
casalli who's down on strikes it's the
first punch out of the day for eric
lauer
he's pumping them in there here in the
second
dubon goes after the o2 going the other
way trotting back is garcia
and the out is recorded
lauer will sit down the side in order in
the second austin slater touched him up
in the first that's why the giants lead
it one nothing after two
bradley strikes out it's been a tough
season for him at the plate and webb has
k number three
that's a pretty good one
shawn will answer later because logan
webb
is oh so economical this afternoon now
nine up nine down
here's the swing get a missed strike
three high fastball he took a big hack
at that one but he missed it that's
lauer's second strikeout in the first
out in the bottom of the third
here's the pitch ruff hits a shot to
left center field yelich going back and
he'll make the catch
and wong is down on strikes logan webb's
fifth punch out already this afternoon
amy g logan webb is looking good
maria's into the corner and that is
going to punch off the wall
and turn into a stand-up double
a one-out double for urias
[Applause]
marias and yelich are on for garcia
2-2 on its way
got him
six strikeouts already for logan webb
on to jace peterson clutch city last
night as well two out two strike rbi
single made it 3-2 that was the go-ahead
run
lofts one into shallow center it's going
to drop and arias is on his way home the
throw is going to catch yelichin between
second and third but the brewers do get
a run yell it's still on the run
crawford is going to make the tag for
the out
to end the inning but the brewers get
their first run of the day
jace peterson a little bloop rbi knock
it scores urias one per side now as
logan webb is shaking his head and
saying a few things that might not be
safe for youtube
cassalli pops one up
here comes garcia for it
there we go again pitching has been
supreme so far today
after four innings lauer's giving up one
run so has webb we sail into the fifth
the pitch on the way swing in the miss
he struck him out with a change up
the second time that he has
punched out jackie bradley jr seven
strikeouts now in four and two third
innings recorded by
logan webb
milly clocks one to left field and he
finds some open space
he's gonna truck to second luke maley
sends a ball all the way into the left
field corner it's a two out double here
in the fifth
freezing
frozen make it
eight strikeouts this afternoon for mr
webb
trying to wipe away this losing skid for
the giants
[Music]
and he rings him up
[Applause]
little nubber
and lauer actually falls back but makes
the fadeaway throw in time
see if he's okay
it looks like
there's yelich with a bouncing ball to
estrada
you can do a nice little workout with
the youtube trophy and brandon crawford
wants another we'll see if he helps his
team out
on offense as logan webb with another
shutdown inning 1-1 mid-six
and slices his bat in half and goes to
left and drops a base hit
and a fastball down in the zone
that's where you give him a chance and
even though he did break his back
but because of the way they've been
economical there's logan webb just not
wasting pitches
it's his ninth strikeout
it's 1-1 in the seventh
and another strikeout victim
double digit punch outs
for logan webb two down vogel back over
two
that's smoked off the bat of vogelback
and it's gonna bounce up against the
right field wall he's heading for second
here comes the throw and they got him
austin slater on the money bogobox
sniffing the double out of the box but
slater comes up fields it clean throws a
strike one hopper right on the bag
crawford puts the quick tag down that is
textbook
[Applause]
that's but lauer has been super
efficient there's a strikeout he heard
you sean
another 3-2 count for dubon today and
this one is skyed
and comes bradley jr and the gold glover
is all over it
with a little leap
colton wong with a smile
three up three down in the seventh eric
lauer has been fantastic today
there is the right-handed hitting chris
bryant
and that's ball four four pitch walk for
chris bryant two out base runner for the
giants in the eighth
two one he's running chris bryant for
second and he is out
[Applause]
luke maylie
delivers and willia domes slaps on the
tag oh they're gonna give that a look
here we go and the conclusion he's safe
chris bryant swipes a bag darren ruff
loves left-handed pitching
and we'll see if he has
the ability to crack the code against
one of the toughest righties in baseball
rough blast one left field and
it's down in the corner here comes brian
the giants grab the lead it's 2-1 and
it's up to tyro estrada this would be
some nice insurance
[Applause]
estrada with a deep drive
left field oh he got all of that won
tyro estrada for three it's 5-1 san
francisco
and look who it is the birthday boy
willie adams last chance for milwaukee
thomas goes to right we'll see if that
one's playable for slater backing up and
if it's fair it's gone it's gone
happy birthday william thomas
number 23 on the season two run shot
ends up in the bay
and now the umpires are gonna get
together and say foul ball
and ted barrett just ejected craig
counsel
this one's on the ground it's gonna be a
tough play at second for estrada of
course he makes it game over hit a home
run make a great play to end the game